dead tired but you know what I gotta do
this for me right now warrior all right
now I've heard about warrior for quite
some time people are calling this like
the Rocky of 2011 so I was really
interested to see it as we all love an
underdog story and it's directed by the
guy who directed miracles so I was there
so the first thing you see in warriors
Tom Hardy and Nick Nolte you can tell
there is some history there Nick Nolte's
Tom Hardy's father and he's sober now
but you can tell back in the day he was
like a really shitty alcoholic abusive
dad and then there's Tom Hardy's brother
the main character of the movie you know
the good guy I call him the good guy
because Tom Hardy he has a complicated
past but all in all he's kind of a dick
but the main character that hero the
movie is the guy who actually played
Owen Lars and attack of the clones and
he's a high school teacher he's really
down on his luck the banks about to take
his house it's always like I used to MMA
fight I need to MMA fight again and
there's this big events like the Super
Bowl of MMA so he's like I'm gonna work
towards that it's like a five million
dollar cash prize who couldn't use that
especially when the bank's about to take
your house only thing his brother Tom
Hardy he's also entering that
competition and you can tell Tom Hardy
he has a grudge he is damaged he wants
to hurt some people
now this movies really well acted and
really well-written like all the
performances are awesome Tom Hardy was
really good you remember when Tom Hardy
was like built like me when he was
Picard's clone in Star Trek nemesis but
it's really interesting cuz you remember
inception he was the funny guy you know
you're like oh I like that guy he's
great in this movie dude he's a machine
he doesn't like people he doesn't want
to talk to people he just wants to punch
people and watch them drop and he does
just that some of these fights he gets
in dude you're like that was so
gratifying I'm actually laughing right
now yeah it's like those kind of
knockouts wonderful to watch and Nick
Nolte was really good in the movie every
character in this movie where you're
like dude I sympathize with you he also
has a moment really like dude you're a
dick and every dick in the movie you're
like oh man that was brutal why'd you
have to show me that I feel bad for you
now except for the main guy he's a good
guy all around you don't hate rocky and
rocky he's just good other people are
complicated people and all-in-all this
movie did the MMA fights really well
sometimes when someone wins dude you
want to jump up out of the auditorium
chair you're like oh yeah other times
it's like the first fight and gladiator
where it's like really close camera
shaking everywhere you're like I don't
know what's happening people are getting
hurt though and I'm gonna level with you
guys by the end of this movie you're
like
man tears stop yeah you want to cry it's
just the way it is everyone's been
ranting and raving about this movie and
I was like all right even if I love this
movie I'm gonna give it one notch down
just because like everyone's gonna just
be like oh just see it it's the Oscar
winner of the year I just gotta you know
fight the system and but I watched
the movie and I was like it's good
really good actually it's like if he
took the Darren Aronofsky family issues
from wrestler and mix them with the
Danny Boyle overcoming obstacles
celebration of life kind of thing you'd
have warrior and any movie where I leave
the movie theater and feel like dude you
know what let's go conquer some
obstacles let's go do something let's go
ice skate uphill and win that's
something so I gotta say warrior is
awesome tacular it was a good movie it
was good had good characters it was well
acted well-written it moved me and yeah
the point of this movie is to overcome
obstacles with Owen Lars and his whole
situation you know he's the good guy you
want to see him succeed but this movie
serves a different purpose and that is
the bane addition tape yeah after
watching this movie I was like yes
Batman's in for a bruising Tom Hardy's
gonna beat the living out of him he
is hardcore so your favorite underdog
story what is it comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
official MMA punch right here
you